[Music]
I've never seen anything like you you
stare death in the face that's why I
chose you
Jamie Foxx is Little John Robin Hood is
played by 28 year old Brit Taron Egerton
you may remember him from his shirtless
seen in the Kingsmen I looked and saw
his face and that the jawline and I said
there that thing is right there now you
have to be a warrior what are we gonna
learn from the origin film of Robin I
think in our version we see him as a
young man who is disillusioned he's
fighting for the bad guys and doesn't
realize and he comes back and his eyes
are open partly through Little John's
intervention we have fun with it you
know there's a twinkle in our eyes it's
has its darkness but it's fine it's like
the action is so cool I fire two arrows
a second in this movie like it's really
cool I can't with accent make one of
Robin Hood's Merry Men is fifty Shades
Jamie Dornan were curious oh and there's
another hot guy behind the camera
Leonardo DiCaprio is producing the film
yeah of course a lot of my friends I
told me you weren't enticing my no it's
not that are you telling the ladies
though that you guys will not be in
tights I mean my tights got pretty tight
I was proud I was promised I wouldn't be
in tights and then we got to the day and
I was like sewn these things up a little
bit but hopefully pull them off
[Music]
[Applause]